Magnus just as you're about to give up
one chess Crown you've taken a new one
so my question is when are you gonna
stop
well I'm gonna stop and somebody stops
me
oh man I took that guy down with my Rook
I'm so badass and your dad was like
Magnus remember where you come from that
was the worst Norwegian accent ever
I mean people use drugs to both prepare
for and to do exams for instance
um
if at some point my level of Chess drops
drastically I might start experimental
but for now I don't see the meat
does this actually work
I think
I know you're guessing just sometimes
your guesses are right
no problem I would say my favorite
player from the past is probably myself
like three four years